with the word of god in his hands every human
being wherever his lot in life may be cast
may have such companionship as he shall choose in
its pages he may hold converse with the noblest
and best of the human race and may listen to
the voice of the eternal as he speaks with men
as he studies and meditates upon the
themes into which the angels desire to look
he may have their companionship he may follow
the steps of the heavenly teacher and listen
to his words as when he taught on mountain
and plain and sea he may dwell in this world
in the atmosphere of heaven imparting to earth's
sorrowing and tempted ones thoughts of hope
and longings for holiness himself coming closer
and still closer into fellowship with the unseen
like him of old who walked with god drawing nearer
and nearer the threshold of the eternal world
until the portal shall open and he shall enter
there he will find himself no stranger the
voices that will greet him are the voices
of the holy ones voices who unseen were on
earth his companions voices that here
he learned to distinguish and to love
he who through the word of god has
lived in fellowship with heaven
will find himself at home in heaven's
companionship education page 127 paragraph one
god is good and all the time the thought just
came to me to encourage you and to urge you
and to appeal to you and to plead with you make
time for the writings of the servant of the lord
she has told us those who neglect the testimonies
will not stand in the last great trial they just
will not stand and so you may wonder why does he
recite from ellen white i'm trying to encourage
people to develop a love for those writings
that are such a blessing when they are read
and re-read if you do not believe me go back and
read steps to christ particularly chapter five
someone wrote me a month ago and said i have
uncertainty about my relationship with god and
i said do two things ask god to speak to you i
believe that's what i said and number two read
steps to christ paragraph five i said pray first
a couple days later i got a text from this person
i have never seen it so clearly i have peace
of mind i thought i had to fix myself before
coming to christ she said my stress has fallen
off i see more clearly how christ receives me
i won't burden you any further
if you won't read her writings
read them to your children if you're a
young person considering a relationship
read messages to young people and letters to
young lovers wherever you are listening to me
around the globe if you're considering
establishing a home finish my words
read adventist home if you're thinking
of bringing children into the world
at this late stage in the world's
history finish my words read child
guidance when you're considering educating your
children finish my words read education if you
need counsel on managing your affairs your funds
what should you read councils on stewardship
what does the bible tell us in second chronicles
2012 2020 believe his prophets socially prosper
read the writings of the one god sent to this
church as an inspired messenger and i make
this recommendation without hesitation without
fear despite the fact that this servant of god
is so widely unpopular because
rebuke is always unpopular
how are you did i depress you well how are you
nice to see you do you love god yes or no raise
a hand god likes that i love god i like him too i
work in the household you see in jesus i love you
i love god he's my friend i let him down sometimes
i do don't tell anyone but he's my friend god is
a nice person jesus is a nice man he's also god
but as a human being he's a nice man he really is
and he loves you individually he loves you if
no one else is alive on the face of the earth
steps to christ page 100 paragraph one
the relations between god and each soul
is as distinct and full as though there were
not another soul upon the earth to share his
watch care not another soul for whom he
gave his beloved son god when you pray
god listens as is no one else is praying
you can't get that attention from biden
sometimes not from your spouse but you get it
finish my words from god somebody say a man for
god uh psalm 100 verse 5 for the lord is good
he really is a nice god all right that's why
we're live if you weren't nice we'd all be dead
and we'd all deserve it is anyone present who's
not the seventh-day adventist raise your hand
say oh you have a handsome man stand up please
stand we're nice people don't be
afraid what's your name stand up son
david oh i have a friend called david williams
outstanding scholar have you been before david
did i welcome you okay thank you for coming
would you kindly tell us who invited you
your mother-in-law where you had no
choice all right well it's nice to see you
it's nice to see you dr david god you don't
go against your mother-in-law if you want to
live long well it's nice to see you god bless
you a double blessing on your mother-in-law
and there must be a wife somewhere if you have a
mother-in-law all right anyone else you're not a
seventh-day adventist anyone else okay if they are
guests at the other family churches thank you very
much i think that's the camera over there where
is it right here and god bless you for joining
us i will ask you now to please preserve reverence
where you are particularly if you're in your homes
monitor your children let them know the word
of god is about to be ministered god must be
respected two while i'm speaking pray for me and
say lord what put your words in that man's mind it
is a serious responsibility to occupy your pulpit
because eternal life is at stake error may drive
people down the road to perdition i don't i've
told god before i prefer to die than deliberately
preach error i've told him that and i mean it put
me to sleep but do not let me stand in a pulpit
and deliberately preach error just to keep the
offerings coming so you ask god put his words
in my mouth jeremiah chapter one verse nine then
say with me then the lord put forth his hand and
touched my mouth and the lord said unto me behold
i have put my words in thy mouth and that's what
i want to speak and favor number three i want you
to think you are made in the image of god through
adam god has given us a mind that separates us
from the animal kingdom we are required to think
isaiah 1 18 come now let us reason together
seth the lord what a beautiful privilege
to sit down with god and reason even though
we're almost always unreasonable god is willing
to listen and when we finish ranting and raving he
tells us this is the way walking in it let's pray
father we come to you in the name of jesus your
son our savior when we come in his name day god
we come in the name of the one who
said i am the resurrection and the life
we come in the name of the one who said let there
be light in the name of the one who said to satan
man shall not live by bread alone but by every
word that proceedeth out of the mouth of god
we come in the name of the one
who raised himself from the dead
we come in the name of jesus who said i and
my father are one in this holy mighty name we
bow asking you forgive us if we've offended you
grant us an infilling of your spirit a brand new
infilling father that he may guide our minds as we
listen to your word i humble myself before you if
i've offended you forgive me i am dirty god i am
clay forgive me and grant me your spirit to direct
my thinking and consequently my speaking let my
words glorify your name you deserve it father
your word says in isaiah 42 verse 8 i am
the lord that is my name my glory will i not
give to another so you take it god all of it but
please grant us the blessing because we need them
now father bless those who listening wherever
they are especially our guests and the little
children boys and girls remember those who've
contracted covert 19 right where they are father
place your hand of merciful healing upon them
god and restore them to full health i commit
this service to your glory guide it i pray from
my heart in jesus name amen let us go to john 16.
it's 7 40 on the dot i'll release
you by 8 15. is that too long okay
what book did i say john what chapter 16 reading
from what verse seven and i'll read from the king
james version of the bible and for those of
you who feel so inclined you may read with me
john 16 reading from verse 7 nevertheless i tell
you the truth this is jesus he is the truth and
he tells us the truth it is expedient for you
that i go in other words it is to your advantage
god always asks for our advantage and the greatest
proof of that is calvary it is expedient for you
that i go away for if i go not away the comforter
will not come unto you but if i depart i will send
him unto you and when he's come he will reprove
the world of three things tell me what they are
of sin and of judgment and of righteousness
you see the problem is sin the solution
the righteousness of christ and there'll be a
judgment to determine who goes down or who goes up
very basic verse 9 read with me of sin because
they believe not on me of righteousness
because i go to my father and you see me no more
of judgment because the prince of this world
is judged now let's go back to 9 8-9 and
when he's come he will reprove the world of
sin and of righteousness and of judgment now
he comments on each one in verses 9 10 and 11
of sin finish that verse because they believe not
on me it's a crime against divinity to doubt god
we are familiar with crimes against
humanity it is a crime against divinity
to doubt god let me show you how horrible it is
go to first john chapter five we read verse 10.
well let's read nine and ten
of first john chapter five
first john towards the back of the bible do you
have it what chapter five what verses nine and ten
are you there read with me if we receive come on
the witness of man the witness of god is greater
for this is the witness of god which he hath
testified of his son now very carefully for stan
he that started again he that believeth on the
son come on have the witness in himself keep
reading he that believeth not come on hath made
him a liar why because he hath not believed what
that god gave of his son we make
god a liar when we doubt his word
a subject a crime against divinity
he that believeth on the son hath the witness and
himself he that believeth not hath made him a liar
because hath not believed in the
testament the record that god gave
of his son to disbelieve god is to call him a liar
if we call god a liar by unbelief
who are we calling a truth teller
you see if i by my behavior call god a liar i am
calling satan a truth teller because one is truth
one is lies listen to john 8 44 go there with
me our subject a crime against divinity john 8
verse 44 some very harsh words from christ
but sometimes harsh words have saving value
but don't make it a habit john 8 verse 44 are you
there read with me ye are of your father the devil
and the lust of your father you will
do he was a murderer from the beginning
and abode not in the truth because there is no
truth in him keep reading when he speaketh a lie
he speaketh of his own for he
is a liar and the father of it
christ is clear the liar is satan
did you see that in the verse who is the liar
then when we by our unbelief call god a liar
what are we calling god without saying it
i won't even say it i'll let you think jesus
says the liar is satan first john 5 10 says
when we don't believe god's testimony we make
him a liar then we're saying that god is really
we don't say it but there's no
need to say it our attitudes
a crime against humanity against
divinity is to disbelieve the word of god
let us go to genesis 1. my favorite book
by the way what's your favorite book
matthew all right brother matthew he used to be
a thief then he met jesus and you wrote the first
gospel all those test collectors were thieves
what's your favorite book revelation who or
roma oh you must be a bible scholar romans
okay what's your favorite book my lovely sister
who or romans okay okay all right genesis 1
reading from verse 1 let's pray again god of
heaven and earth god of truth whose spirit
is truth whose son is truth help us to love
truth that we may be children of the truth in
jesus name i pray amen read verse 1 of genesis
1 without looking down in the beginning god
created the heaven and the earth let's think
sometimes in the bible heaven and earth
means everywhere go to matthew 28 without
losing genesis 1 matthew 28 read verse 18. i just
said sometimes heaven and earth means everywhere
matthew 28 reading verse 13 not 13
sorry verse 18. do you have that
read with me come on read verse 8 in matthew 28
and jesus came and spake unto them saying what
all power is given unto me where in heaven and
in earth now think with me how much power is given
unto jesus all where question for you is there a
place where jesus has no power no then what does
heaven and earth mean in that verse everywhere
now in genesis 1 it means the heavens connected
to the earth our solar system because there was
a place where angels lived before this earth
was made are you following me so the entire
universe wasn't made in genesis 1 1 but it doesn't
change the fact that it was made by god now in the
beginning god created the heaven and the earth he
made the entire universe that tells us what he did
when you see it if you ever been to a is it called
what's that national park that has the oldest
trees in the world huh no it's in california or
somewhere on the west coast big trees that rise
to hundreds of feet the sequoia tree where is that
oh sequoia national park all right there's there's
a tree somewhere it's about 5 000 years old if
you cut that tree down you see a lot of rings
that's how they date trees you know who allows
trees to live be more specific in the name jesus
have you ever seen a bird fly you
know who created the laws of flight
jesus you're blinking your eyes as you look at
me you cannot blink your eye unless you lose
muscular contraction and that requires electrical
impulses do you know who set that in place jesus
i love going to the ocean i don't swim well
but i love to go to the ocean and splash
you don't drown when you splash the waves come in
do they come in yes or no then what did they
do go back out who put that law in place
jesus the bible say thus far and no further
by the way the waves obey better than we do
the internal system of the body great mystery
all the organs all the systems they function
by jesus christ now in the beginning god created
the heaven and the earth everything in it that's
what he did question now is how how go to verse
3 quickly of genesis 1. read verse 3 for me and
god said stop i talk about this all the time
and god said do you have god said in your hand
what do you mean why are you hesitating
do you have god said in your hand
short to me this how was the
entire universe created by this
not by ink and paper by the word listen to
education page 126 paragraph four the creative
energy that called the worlds into existence
is in the word of god this word imparts power
it begets life every command is a promise
accepted by the will receive into the soul
it brings with it the life of the infinite one who
is the incident one god it transforms the nature
and recreates the soul in the image of god
this word brings to us the very life of god
let the bible establish that go to
genesis 1 let's read from verse 11.
what's our subject a crime against divinity we're
reading from verse 11 of genesis 1. it's 9 minutes
to 8. let's pray father as i talk about your word
which you have magnified above your nail in psalm
138 verse 2 give me clarity of speech and humility
of heart i pray in jesus name amen read verse 11
with me and god said let the earth bring forth
grass the building seed and the fruit yielding
fruit after his kind whose seed is in itself upon
the earth and it was so verse 12 and the earth
brought forth grass an herb yielding seed now
stop what's in the seed life go to verse 29
behold i've given you every herb bearing
seed which is upon the face of all the earth
and every tree in the witch is the fruit of a
tree yielding seed the seed is what produces
the tree because there is the principle
of life in the seed put there by god
and called forth by god now are trees living
things yes or no yes is grass a living thing
yes do they have a kind of life yes can grass die
yes do trees die yes when it's hot does your lawn
shrivel up and die yes because they have life
anything that lives lives by the power of god
anything that lives and the power
of god is mediated through his word
go to hebrews 1. let's read
verse 3. let's read from verse 1
of hebrews 1. our subject a crime against divinity
you have hebrews 1 reading from verse 1
keep going keep going all right somebody
found it okay all right let's read god
who at sundry times and in diverse manners speak
in time past unto the fathers by the prophets that
in these last days spoken unto us by his son now
read very carefully whom he hath appointed heir
of all things by whom also he made the
world so the father told the son you create
now verse 3 carefully who being the brightness of
his glory and the express image of his person and
upholding all things how by the word of his
power or his powerful word the verse says
the creator which is christ upholds all things by
the word of his power go now to colossians 1. keep
all things in your mind and go to colossians 1.
we read 1617 our subject a crime against divinity
colossians not far from hebrews just go to the
left a few books you should run into colossians
who wrote colossians brother paul
a busy man a powerful preacher
tradition says he was short bore-legged and
ball-headed that's how he's described in
secular writings not in the bible colossians
1 reading from verse 16 read with me now
for by him were all things created stop we have
the expression all things do you see it there
all right for by him were all things created
that are in heaven and that are in earth visible
and invisible whether they be thrones or
dominions or principalities or powers all
things were created by him and for him and he is
before all things and by him all things consists
you cannot see without this creative
word of god sustaining the laws of sight
are you with me everything god
does he does through his word
go to matthew 8
other than yourself who is your
greatest enemy satan all right matthew 8
when i say other than yourself i wasn't joking
if the devil dies right now we will still sin
we don't sin because there's a devil we sin
because we have a nature that leans that way
and we choose not to seek spiritual power
if we do not sin because the devil tempts us
i'm not promoting temptation i'm simply saying
sin is a choice we make what book did i say
which one matthew 8 verse 3 verse 16 are you
there read with me and when the evil was come
they brought unto him many that were possessed
how with devils keep reading and he cast out the
spirits how with his word now what does that teach
you your weapon against the devil is the word
if it was the weapon for jesus
how can you use a different weapon
we have to learn to rebuke the enemy in
the name of jesus christ and by his word
now we've discovered that the word christ used
is that the weapon christ used is the word
now let's look at a part of the mission
of christ go to first john chapter three
our subject a crime against divinity four
minister eight first john chapter three
we were there earlier this is the same person who
wrote the gospel of john and who wrote revelation
by the way same person he wrote five books the
gospel of john revelation and first second and
third john first john 3 8 read with me he
that committed sin is of the devil for the
devil sinneth from the beginning finish the verse
for this purpose the son of god was manifested
that he might destroy the works of the devil
now what is the weapon that jesus uses the word
i want you to look at that verse one of the
purposes christ came into the world is to destroy
the works of the devil question for you but
don't answer me is the devil working in your life
don't answer me
you want him out studied and obeyed
not recited like mary had a little lamb studied
and obeyed the power of the word is released in
obedience but obedience is merely the expression
of faith are you are you listening to me
obedience is merely the ex when i go to the
dance and he tells me sit down i sit down
i don't ask him why i sit down then he leans the
chair all the way back and i'm like this i'm in
a coffin you open your mouth out of my mouth he
says bite down i bite down i've never said why
never said why once in a while i go to my
chiropractor to make sure things are in order
because i love to lift weights you need to check
your body and she tells me raise a knee i raise a
knee she says resist i resist she said turn over
face down i turn over face down i've never asked
hawaii because she has this lift kit on the wall
are you listening to me she has a certificate on
the wall from an accredited school i go to the
mechanic he says pop the hood i pop the hood
god says keep the sabbath we say no
why why now god says listen to me i'm not a
mechanic i'm not a chiropractor i'm not a i am god
i made the chiropractor i made the mechanic
i made the dentist keep myself no why
but everybody loves jesus
this is the weapon against the enemy
its power is released in obedience
what's our subject a crime against
divinity to doubt the word of god
i uh i love to talk about the word of god
when christ comes back the second time go
to first thessalonians four is eight o'clock
on the dot when did thy shadow release you
how many have to go to work can i see your hand
nobody all right that's not a threat i'll finish
by yet 15. what book did i say first what chapter
reading first whenever an adventist preacher goes
to first thessalonians four you can guess what
verse he's reading what verse is that 16 answer
you can just guess and be right 16. well since
you guessed the first say it without looking for
the lord himself shall descend from heaven with
a shout come on with the voice of the archangel
and with the trumpet of god and the dead
in christ shall rise first now look closely
at that verse the lord himself i like that
by the way he's not sending someone for us
someone sends an uber to pick you up not
christ the lord is coming for you him
that tells you how he thinks of you are you
with me all right for the lord himself shall
descend from heaven how with a shout but
god does not make noises god utters words
ah you miss what i said the word
shout doesn't mean god just said
when god speaks he utters words but he
utters the word so loud the writer says
i shall are you with me but it's a word with a
shout keep reading with the voice of the archangel
that's another description of what the shout is
like it's the word he's be with the trump of god
is that the sound of a trumpet in other words
when he comes he says something but it's loud
now listen to this verse but don't go this
listen and when he thus had spoken he cried
with a loud voice lazarus finish the verse
come forth verse 44 of john 11 says and he
that was bound hand on foot came forth where
was christ when he raised lazarus in the tomb
outside the tomb where was lazarus in the tomb did
christ touch him no what did christ do he spoke
then there must be life come on in the world
in a way we do not understand now this is the
man who raised lazarus when you raise this the
widow's son name he touched the coffin not the boy
now he can touch if he wants but the word of god
does not require a touch he just said lazarus
come forth and lazarus came to him now listen
to first thessalonians 4 16 for the word for
the lord himself shall descend from heaven with
a shout with the voice of the archangel and with
the trump of god and the dead in christ shall
rise first jesus comes shouts from the heaven
and all righteous dead people get up that is the
power of the word of god now go to ephesians 5.
now let me speak to those who spiritually
dead in this building and online
how did jesus raise lazarus you tell me he said
lazarus come forth he came forth now we're talking
to the spiritually dead ephesians 5 read for me
verse 14 clearly and carefully what does it say
wherefore he saith what awake thou that sleep is
and arise from the dead and christ shall give thee
life now this is spoken to those spiritually dead
and if someone receives that word into the heart
that person will come from the spiritual
death as lazarus came from the physical death
awake felt asleep is an arise from
the dead jesus virtually told lazarus
arise from the dead when he said come
forth when those words are received
someone is brought to life spiritually and so
ephesians 2 verse 1 says you hath he quickened
who were dead in trespasses and sins how by
the quickening word of god and so jesus tells
us in john 6 63 it is the spirit that
quickeneth the flesh prophet is nothing
the words that i speak unto you finish the
verse they are spirit and they are life
the very life of god is in his word
and to belittle the word is to belittle
god listen to what samuel told saul then
i'll let you go first samuel 15 let's
go to verse 22 and 20 verses 22 and 23.
first number 15 22-23 and i'll close
should be short on saturday night
first samuel 15 22-23 you have that i'll give you
10 more seconds to find it for sam for samuel is
the first of the great prophets but who was the
very first prophet in the bible the very first
you're talking too softly i can't hear you
who is the very first prophet in
the bible nope good guess but no who
can't hear my handsome brother okay enoch first
prophet yes first samuel 15 22 23 let me pray
father i'm closing now but continue to help me
i pray in jesus name amen listen to what samuel
tells saul after saul disobeyed god are you with
me read with me and samuel said hath the lord as
great delight in burnt offerings and sacrifices
as in obeying the voice of the lord keep reading
behold to obey is better than sacrifice under
hearken than the fat of ram verse 23 now go on
for rebellion is as a sin of and idolatry
as and stubbornness as idolatry and
now and finish the verse because thou has
rejected the word of god he also has rejected thee
you reject this you've rejected me
there are people in church who have rejected
god but they come to church every sunday
when you reject thus saith the lord you reject
god because that's the name of jesus revelation
19 13 and he was clothed in a vesture dipped with
blood and his name is called the word of god john
1 verse 1 in the beginning was the word and the
word was with god and the word was god verse 14
and the word became was made flesh and dwelt among
us when you say no to truth you say no to god
the bible says in proverbs 8 36
all they that hate me love death
i offer to you tonight the word of god let me
close with this passage go to john 6 quickly
johnson we'll read a long
passage and i close it's uh 808
i promise let's go by 8 15 but if the
spirit touches me i may have to go to
8 20. are you with me all right so blame
the spirit not me john 6 from verse 51
you have that are you there read with me what
does it say i am the living bread which came
down from heaven if any man eat of this bread he
shall live forever and the bread that i will give
is my flesh which i will give for the life of the
world you notice we have the word life and living
occurs several times between verse 51 and further
down almost nine ten times he's talking about life
the jews therefore strove among themselves
saying how can this man give us his flesh to eat
they misunderstood the words of christ and
misunderstanding is a very dangerous thing
it leads to all kinds of catastrophic
behavior but they misunderstood because
they are listening with carnal mind not with
a mind to see the beauty of truth that saves
then jesus said unto them verily verily i say
unto you except ye eat the flesh of the son
of man and drink his blood finish the verse ye
have no life in you who so eat of my flesh verse
54 and drinketh my blood hath eternal life and i
will raise him up at the last day keeper day for
my flesh is meat indeed and my blood is drink
indeed he that eateth my flesh and drinketh my
blood dwelleth in me and i in him as the living
father have sent me and i live by the father
so he that eateth me even he shall live by me
keep reading this is that bread that came down
from heaven not as your fathers that eat manna
and are dead he that eateth of this bread come on
shall live forever now read verse 59 these
things said he in the synagogue come on
as he taught in capernaum now with the next
verse many of his disciples therefore when
they heard this said this is a hard
saying who can hear it this is tough
they said a lot of people walk out of churches
because they don't like what's being preached
so the preacher says you should not live with
a woman not your wife then get up and walk out
walking out on a preacher does not change
the truth are you following me are you
uh come on you don't like me anymore walking
out on a preacher does not change the truth
maybe therefore of his disciples when they
heard this said this is a hard saying this
rough stuff who can hear it verse 61 read with
me when jesus knew it himself that his disciples
murmured at it he said unto them does
this offend you you know the sabbath
the seventh day of the sabbath offends many people
it offends people because it interferes
with custom christ describes a sad situation
in luke 5 37-39 and i'll apply it to why many
people reject the seventh-day sabbath which is
bible truth go to luke 5 quickly the spirit just
told me to go there let me go quickly without
rushing luke 5 37-39 a crime against divinity do
you have that luke was a medical doctor he was not
uh one of the twelve disciples he is the only
non-jewish writer in the bible are you there now
read with me and no man did i tell you the verses
37-39 read with me and no man put it new wine come
on in all bottles else the new wine will burst
the bottles and to be spilled and the bottle shall
perish but new wine must be put into new bottles
and both are preserved now carefully verse 39
no man also having drunk or wine strictly
desire is new for he saith finish the verse
the old is better now this is sad the new
wine means the doctrines christ brought
which the pharisees could not accept because
their hearts weren't changed so christ's new
wine teachings had no effect upon them listen
to verse 39 no man also having drunk old wine
strictly desireth the new let me put it in simple
language when you've been brought up on error
your initial reaction to truth
is very often very very negative
one of the great tragedies of society
is something called recidivism
recidivism a brother goes to jail anybody goes to
jail talk about the men spends eight ten years you
let him out he goes right back because he's become
accustomed to that life you let him out again he
goes right back it's called recidivism he doesn't
have to work three meals a day he can play he or
whatever he goes right back it's a sad situation
when you're grown up in error and you see truth
you tremble you because you realize i'm
losing the comfort of what i'm accustomed to
but it is wrong yes it's wrong but i'm accustomed
and when you're accustomed you're comfortable
and jesus said no man verse 39 luke 5 having drunk
new wine having drunk old wine strictly desireth
new for he saith the old is better he said that's
what my grandfather did and my father that's
what my tribe did that's what this community does
that's what this parish does how can i change that
truth is not automatically loved are you
following me because truth goes contrary to
the carnal nature let's go back to john 6 verse 62
61 when jesus knew it himself that his disciples
murmured at it he said unto them doth disoffend
you of course they were offended now read verse 66
carefully for me come on read it what does it say
from that time many of his disciples went back and
walked no more with him why did they
leave they did not like what he said
now then said jesus unto the 12 67 will he also
go away then simon peter answered him lord to whom
shall we go come on finish it thou has the words
of eternal life now peter is saying we are staying
for this reason you preach come on the truth
and he calls them the words of eternal life
you join a church because of what it teaches
not because the members are nice because the
place to find hypocrites is not a casino finish
my word isn't a church ah you stop listening let
me go home the place to find hypocrites is
the church not the bar and the strip club
so if you're coming to the church looking for
perfect people you've come the wrong place
you come looking for thus saith the lord are you
with me and so peter said lord to whom shall we go
that's why i've always said if i were to leave the
adventist church i couldn't join another church
i'd just go into the world and drink and smoke
and whatever jump off cliffs and whatever
are you following me go to another church
for what having learned what i've learned
and have been taught we are staying
because you speak the words of life
you don't have a church building but you
preach the truth your members don't drive cars
but you preach the truth you don't have a fancy
pipe organ but you've preached the words of
life we have to learn how to reduce life to the
essentials and that is truth and to reject it
is a crime against humanity how can you
doubt someone who said let there be light
and the light came and then you doubt him
that's an insult insult that's why we call
him a lie or that's how we call him a liar let
me ask you quickly it's 8 16 forgive me 8 16.
how many will say lord increase my love for the
truth can i see your hair stand up with me please
now i want two short prayers short
i want one from this side one from
that side i'll pray let's all kneel